[Music]
in mobile office news submitted by you
ain't got the answers sway public
parking spots are being turned into
temporary outdoor office spaces oh don't
you gotta pay for it by the hour then
yeah they're saying it's cheaper than
renting
I heard hookers in Germany be doing this
[ __ ] they got their mobile home in
different areas and then they just have
a mobile hooker service legally yeah
it's legal over there it's amazing
uber uber uber that's also do something
there I gotta work in a sex industry
now what am I doing here no no no you're
in the right industry - no you should
get out here I'm not the okay do you
look like a porn video director you just
want to be in the video he just wants to
direct the vision yeah he's a visionary
I just want to make money off of people
have a sex jamali of productions then
put your own [ __ ] up online I'm sure
your bank know that's really gonna last
little I would more readily watch a joke
porn than just like a random you know
there'd be some sort of his penis thank
you you don't know it's weird to watch
your friends in the porno I wouldn't
watch my friends but if my children muff
is directed oh I see yeah he says I have
creativity he already said you wasn't
gonna be any he said you know I was like
you should direct one would it be a
comedy porno you told me about this
article yeah let's move on to the
article okay so she was very interested
you jerk I know funny every time I want
to get we also have a new rule that we
need to get to the article just like
right now and then when I want to engage
you guys are like shut the [ __ ] up [ __ ]
y'all you know I have never said that to
you TIFF I only want to hear you speak
okay all the time let me tell you about
this articles and look at this now
you're talking over me
when I see her when she gets loud though
it's like it's really loud it's crazy
but it's crazy but you're the only one
that still hears her yeah it's wrong
her loudness goes to this much space and
then it dies it fizzles away but it's
loud in this space yeah within like one
what do you mean I mean I see next door
during JK party all that stuff when
she's hollering I'm like damn I've never
heard you this loud and I go like this
far away and it dissipates yeah how can
I make it not disappear that's a from
the gut that's what I've been trying to
do you sleep from the nose that's cuz
you're paying attention but you never
listen to her when she does you guys
I've become that mom hey you guys just
two now [ __ ] listen all the time
testing why not test me what kind of mom
don't you guys mean on this one see this
man named Victor he's the organizer of
we park and so he we work yeah that
makes me miss best title so you saying
what if we use parking look at his logo
anything else we park oh my god
definitely a Chinese person huh
that is so [ __ ] funny this started in
San Fran and now it's like move into
different cities all over though is this
a joke no it looks like a joke
they're pretty much saying I mean this
does look like a joke could you just
make your office and anything like you
can go to the park and just yeah so why
do you take over spaces that people
actually need in a crowded city I
totally agree because this actually kind
of bothers me a little bit unless
specifically providing electrical
outlets and Wi-Fi pay for like a spot to
do work I'm probably gonna need I get
what you're saying you make a lot of
sense it was just the way you go back
title just stick to it was a loose can
you imagine you have to go meet someone
in downtown and you've been driving
around for like 30 minutes
and then you're looking for a parking
space and yeah [ __ ] right there
exactly what I always think maybe they
don't have that problem in German what
what just happened is I would take my
shitty beat-up car and just slowly inch
towards them whoa whoa
and then their stuff slowly gets crushed
I just parked my car and they're just
hitting my car stop it you saw that
table it was on wheels
yeah so if you have an office chair like
this it's on wheels you could slowly
push them guys walk just gonna get
sanded from the bottom yeah or if you do
it slowly slow enough it'll go and it's
gonna grind yeah yeah like how much does
that cost I need to know like six bucks
an hour they're saying that loaf eparchy
public parking could be used for other
purposes like there's also this other
thing called parking day or something
Larkin we are you parking at these
parking oh poor kid and he's Park you
okay this other one is where they're
actually creating little parks on a
parking space well I don't know do they
not have far apart we're missing
something here there's something in
Germany that no it's not a Germany in
Germany I said the Germany part because
there's legal prostitution in Germany
you know I thought we were in Germany
for a second as well Bristol la Portland
LA we need the parking well here's the
thing we need the parking San
Francisco's wave work exactly what the
[ __ ] are they doing in my mind if that
was true if I live in specially what the
photo with the guy that had his desk
there but he was next to a [ __ ] Park
dock it's free yes right there like
Anthony said but maybe they're offering
electrical outlet and Wi-Fi oh my god we
have a question this one was clearly an
advertisement though I hope it's on the
website if you're a parking if you're a
parking attendant and you're keeping
track of cars do you go there every hour
and then use a chalk and mark on their
desk to come back can you like can you
like valet a [ __ ] desk are they going
to the meters where you just put like
coins or like a card or whatever those
are the ones and they're saying that
it's cheaper to do that not only because
like this one for example it doesn't
have me
they're almost a parking space that
they're allowing the shitty public like
the the street like they're saying like
we can use this play this space because
we are like the city is gonna shut that
yeah because the city owns the streets
yeah I mean there's a lot of other
places like the LA River has a lot of
open space for the [ __ ] homeless
dudes that practice [ __ ] sword
fighting there you know what I'm talking
about right that's why I want them to be
there yeah you could go to library you
got for free there's die berry because
that's the same thing as like squatting
right cuz a homeless person can't just
pitch up their tent like legally they
have to get removed they will get
removed like a copy tone the move out
the way that's the same [ __ ] but it's
not the same [ __ ] because the homeless
persons on the sidewalk they're using a
parking space they're just not using it
to park the car they're parking their
desk they carry that desk right I guess
everywhere else would be considered
loitering but it's not idle parking
space maybe this is just phenomenal that
none of us understand right now but you
know we have an office space right here
because they're paying for it I'm
lighting this [ __ ] on fire that's all I
know I just think it's [ __ ]
inconsiderate and I'm an inconsiderate
[ __ ] honestly I feel like I'm
also missing something cause like I
tried reading every read this article a
couple of times and I'm like I don't get
it what is where I think it's cooling
over let's say they have a mobile home
right and instead of using it for hooker
purposes it's a mobile office and you
park your car there and then you pay the
[ __ ] meter and then you work in there
for some reason I just have an issue
with them outside I feel you because of
cars not parked there if a car was
parked there I go I'd get it like it's
made for a vehicle because it's being
used I feel like it's being used even if
it's I don't know so like they do they
that's like if they put a car on a swing
I bet why the [ __ ] is there a car on a
swing let me swing on it yeah that's
true you've seen that before no I'm just
saying and sex I yeah so lunch trucks do
this all the time they they take over
parking spaces they'll take the ticket
because sometimes it's worth the ticket
yeah take a two hundred dollar ticket
cuz they'll make way more at the end of
this article it has the guy that I
mentioned that started this thing he
says so he it says that he admits that
we park has an intentional
tongue-in-cheek quality and he says that
the project makes an important state
that public spaces should be for anyone
and that you can use that space even if
it's just as faults under the Sun which
is true but there's a ton of other
public spaces that's not intrusive rocks
libraries there's a ton of places
especially because it's so [ __ ] hard
to get parking in San Francisco in LA I
said what thought [ __ ] yeah Starbucks
like most people in San Francisco do you
[ __ ] nuts or go to a park if you want to
be outside I'm not for police brutality
but in this case yes I would love to see
like riot control come and shoot teargas
at them and then those [ __ ] beanbags
at that group of the office orgy people
I'm just telling you just get a [ __ ]
beat-up car and you slowly inch them out
and crush their [ __ ] and even when you
walk out don't even give them a reaction
just get out the cart you screaming at
you don't even acknowledge them guess
how mad they would be you [ __ ]
[ __ ] we don't need to we just need to
have a bunch of Asian moms that need to
be somewhere in that area they'll be
like [ __ ] you you're not using it no
I'll just sit there look at their stuff
the whole time manage your money well
yeah so they're saying that that they
just had that one parking spot what
could you do if you had more people in
more spot no that means no parking spots
I know even if it was a dude that had a
motorcycle and he parked there and he
pulled out his laptop and he goes I'm
gonna work here for three hours that'd
be cool with me he has a vehicle in a
place that's meant for a vehicle yeah
but I think because they're trying to be
so like counterculture that allows me
the wrong way yeah it does because what
if they fill up all the spaces in the
city and now for the [ __ ] of people what
if they all work for the Department of
Transportation I mean this one here I
don't know what does that mean these
belong to them but these could belong to
them
take this sit on the motorcycle and work
on it so you could park another card
that I were the [ __ ] deaths are yeah
well I think it's because we know how
hard it is to find parking and it's like
they're doing it in the cities that I
needed the most how would they what
years this is Integra and Eclipse how
would they feel if humans started
shading in the dog park
that's not for duty too
but you don't see humans going it's a
public party space I'm [ __ ] pulling
their pants out let's try [ __ ] and
peeing over there I just didn't consider
like even if you let's say there was
somebody who had a house and then you
just kind of post it up and had a picnic
on the sidewalk in front of their house
public space yeah and you opened up a
barbecue you started yeah yeah I mean
[ __ ] you park on the dare you [ __ ]
mommy public space dude
kind of understanding that what looking
at you through the mirror winner cuz the
library is a public space so wiener
most people use libraries yeah that's
weird that's all [ __ ] weird it's the
act like public spaces don't exist yeah
you [ __ ] [ __ ] bags or the six
thousand benches inside of a mall this
just makes me want to burn that app to
the ground it's like a movement or
something no it's not a movement dudes
but well they're [ __ ] that movement it's
[ __ ] stupid
[Music]